hey guys so I'm in New York right now I
just shot a really fun show and I can't
wait for you guys to see whatever it was
that I was shooting here but in the
meantime I just got completed with that
project and now I'm gonna head to lunch
and just wander around New York until my
flight tonight it's a very late flight
so not sure that's gonna be too exciting
or not also New York Fashion Week so
there is a ton of people here dressed up
in I guess fashionable outfits
they look a little silly but I think
that's the name of the game of fashion
they're probably saying the same thing
about me she looks silly my fashion game
is okay yeah I look silly let's go
explore New York for a bit shall we
it's like a most terrifying thing I've
ever seen in my life what are what what
I'm not sure what it's called this like
this really good pizza place that this
morning one of the makeup artist was
recommending I forget what it's called
it's called uh you do numero 28 numero
28 people shout 28 shall we do that
yeah I'm gonna figure it out it's pretty
close it's something in blinker it
starts as a si si and be something in
Bleeker a box
why don't you do it I mean in this run
it's probably really just one with the
drive in traffic what do you think I'll
do whatever got along I might need a
snack along the way though because I'm
hungry I left all my snacks upstairs
and then yeah I would love to go to the
Nike store maybe or we don't have much
room to pack guitars going on a long
trip it has no room published luggage is
overweight every time
my favorite stores exotic and Voltaire
I'm not sure if that's how you pronounce
it that's actually what this bag is it's
Fashion Week I'm feeling fashionable
let's keep this got any good bags and
zadig
had so many cute items but not the right
size
no I there's this really cute pair of
shoes I saw and she kog'maw to me on my
brain which I forgot to really mention
the hair stylist today she's like do you
want a different kind of braid I'm like
yes please
a fishtail braid is so cute I tried to
do it before but I can't do it I need to
watch more YouTube tutorials or olicity
that we're like a mile away so alright
yeah we're gonna burn off that piece
looks good there's a really good coffee
place over here that I went into one
it's really cool it's like there's not
like a bunch of trees it's indoor I
think it's up that way somewhere might
have checked in on swarm so I can look
back in my history forgot about swarms
I got a phone and we didn't ever put it
back on only ten minutes okay I'll catch
some Pokemon oh wow there's so many we
made it to numeral 28 this is super cute
have like a little brick oven
I really want to find a really cool pet
store and have like cool pet clothes I
wonder if there aren't I'm going to look
it up
bertrise
I hope she first courses are salads they
look delicious mother sweet pizza
this looks so good the Pizza Rustica
sausage
this might be the most incredible people
that I've had in a really long time a
lot of like four minutes
Pizza was Incredibles oh my gosh I kind
of want like a iced mocha that's
basically like ice cream no no gross
we're all okay fine I'll have a mint
chocolate ice cream whatever
this looks so good this is basically an
eating vlog what will I eat next I'm not
sure
oh my god
mint chocolate chip is over th an
apricot whoever got the - wow that ice
cream is so good the pizza was delicious
New York it's a very perfect day today I
got to go back and take a nap I think
because my flight is late to be
basically I get it in like 1:30 they
leave here at 10:30 hopefully there's no
delays cuz I'm tired I had to get up at
4 o'clock this morning and I didn't
sleep at all last night because anyhow I
have to get up early I'm super paranoid
that I'm not gonna wake up every hour on
the hour sometimes a few minutes passed
I woke up in a panic thinking I
overslept but I didn't and now I'm
extremely exhausted quick zip to New
York let's take a nap and then get on
the plane I just accidentally slept for
almost three hours and I almost missed
my flight
the flights not for a while but I did
almost sleep through my car coming to
pick me up so I need to pack up really
quick and get going so delirious alright
just make sure we have all of our items
and look at the road
Manesh the airport it is I have a lot of
time before my flight the car picked me
up pretty early because sometimes I can
take a really long time to get to the
airport from the actual city so I'm just
sitting and reading I just ordered a
grilled cheese I'm not proud of the
things that I've eaten today definitely
not the healthiest of choices but it's
been a pretty tasty day so I figured hey
why not girl cheese is on the menu I'm
gonna get it the Steeler game is on so
I'm glad I get to catch at least last
quarter of that before I hop on the
flight I'm excited to show you guys
JetBlue mint it's like the craziest
flight seeding ever you'll see here in a
second
[Music]
three four this is ridiculous I'm never
eating illegally
[Music]
this is so crazy just shut the door I'm
in my hole
this is bigger than my first apartment
at Los Angeles
[Music]
looks good
I feel like a princess
[Music]
listen I made it back safely I don't
think I got back to my house until super
late
I was so delirious that I woke up and
forgot that I was home dog was growling
but he was growling from the outside cuz
Janna
ended up taking him out for a walk this
morning so I didn't have to and I could
sleep in but I'm home I just got back
from the gym and Jen and I are gonna run
some errands today and probably make a
vlog about it so stay tuned for that
really riveting content coming up soon
well I'll see you guys the next video
it's a big week for the iPhone let me
know what you guys want me to make this
week in regards to iPhone videos and
I'll see you soon bye that I'm getting
from you guys is is mostly concerns
about how are you going to listen to
music while charging your phone it's an
issue